bonjour je m'appelle Salvatore Montana
il y a longtemps j'ai travaillé pour le
fameux commendator Enzo Ferrari
moi je suis ici comme tous les jours
Salvatore sera au garage le sien depuis
plus de 50 ans moi j'ai fait des
miracles dans les réparations automobile
de miracles
chez Ferrari
j'étais très jeune j'avais je sais pas
si j'avais 17 ans on était impressionné
c'est un grand monsieur avec un gros nez
qui arrive
[Musique]
j'étais responsable du département des
courses quelques véganiers ensemble
les 24 Heures du Mans c'est la course
d'endurance la plus réputée au monde en
tête la Ferrari numéro 19
à 64 ces fois là j'étais engueulé par la
directrice de Ferrari il m'a dit quand
la course est terminée tout doit
permettre de côté parce que les
photographes il aime plus ta gueule que
la gueule des pilotes
et ce beau garçon se souvient
parfaitement du chant de la victoire
qu'il fredonnait avec ses équipiers de
Ferrari Orléans
mais la fête italienne au monde pouvait
durer éternellement
en 1966 Ford finit par vaincre Ferrari
juste après le départ de Salvatore les
Américains en eux-mêmes fait un film
vous étiez mauvais perdant
si Salvatore a quitté le monde des
courses si jeunes au début de la
vingtaine c'est parce qu'il a émigré au
Québec pour fondre une famille et ouvrir
son garage et le voilà 58 ans plus tard
toujours au travail avec son fils
Anthony j'ai jamais tout de suite parce
que on s'en est jamais parlé c'est
vraiment le film qui m'a fait poser des
questions ben non parce que jeunes quand
lui comme je t'ai dit émigré ici il
s'est mis à travailler pour la famille
pour nous faire pour nous nourrir on a
maintenant la preuve qu'on a vraiment un
Québécois qui a travaillé pour Enzo
Ferrari qui a été un passionné puis qui
a été un des bons mécanicien Denzo cette
décision Salvatore ne l'a pas regretté
mais lors des passages des Ferrari et
Formule 1 à Montréal il a appris avec le
temps à se tenir loin et puis quand ces
moteurs
je voulais être à côté de lui
c'était trop fort à moi j'ai en pleurer
[Musique]
ça
à grande ingénieur
un grand essayeur de voiture parce que
j'avais du talent à 80 ans Salvatore
adore sa vie il a retraite ce n'est pas
pour demain nous travaillons
j'ai pas terminé encore jamais trop ça
c'est mon bébé Jean-François Poirier
Radio-Canada Saint-Jean-sur-Richelieu